Lopyrev: Hey, everyone,
and welcome to our session.
My name is Anton Lopyrev,
and I'm a product manager
on the Google API
infrastructure team,
and later on, I'll be joined by
Monsur Hossain and Joe Gregorio.
They're two engineers
on the Google's API
infrastructure team,
and, uh, this is
a 200-level session,
so we'll be covering
some concepts
that could be advanced for you,
but hopefully, you'll be okay.
And--and this session is called
"Building Custom Client
Libraries for Google APIs."
However, some of the concepts
that we will cover
in this session
can be applicable for building
other tools for Google APIs,
such as I.D. plugins
and API explorers
and a few other things,
and we'll talk more about this
as we go on.
And if you want to tweet
about the session,
you can use the hashtags here,
and we would love your feedback
about the session,
so you can use SpeakerMeter,
and just follow this goo.gl
link--it's ifSQM.
So let's have a look
at the outline
of things we're gonna cover
in the session.
So first of all,
we're gonna introduce you
to the APIs Discovery Service.
This is a service that
we launched on Monday this week,
and it's the secret sauce
that powers the new family
of Google API client libraries.
So, um, I will be doing that,
and then Monsur will come here
and talk about a walk-through
of the format,
and he'll give you all the juicy
details of the information
that's available to you
through the service.
And then Joe will join,
and, um, he will tell you
how one can go about
and build a client library
on top of the Discovery Service.
He'll give you an overview
of the steps necessary
to build a library,
and he'll also give you a demo
of a fully functional
Python client library
built on this service, and you
should definitely stick around.
It'll also be
a really cool demo.
Just to give you an idea,
the entire client library
is only 35 lines of code
in Python, so it's really cool
and gives you an idea of how
powerful this service is, so...
With that, let's jump
into the first section,
so introducing the APIs
Discovery Service.
So before I tell you
exactly what it is,
if you haven't yet read
our blog post,
let's quickly overview
how Google builds APIs.
So we had a session
at the last Google I/O,
which we called
"How Google Builds APIs,"
and there, we gave you
a sneak peek behind the scenes
of how we do things at Google,
and I highly recommend
bookmarking this link
and, uh, watching
this YouTube video at home,
since it's--it's some
really cool stuff.
So, um, for the sake
of this session,
I'm gonna give you
a quick overview
of a few important points
of that session.
The first one is that
Google APIs are RESTful,
and I'm not gonna go into detail
as to what that really means.
Hopefully, you all know,
and if you don't,
you should look it up,
but the key idea here
for the sake of this session
is that an API is typically
a collection of resources,
it's a collection of methods
on those resources,
and it's a collection
of parameters for each method.
And another important point
of that session
was also that all of
the newer Google APIs
are based on top of
the new common infrastructure,
and we talked a lot
about this infrastructure
here at Google I/O.
However, what--
an important point here is,
is that the new infrastructure
gives us a new cool way
to build client libraries
for Google APIs.
So this instant,
an API configuration
is structured into
a RESTful model.
It allows us to create
machine-readable specification
for each of the APIs,
and here at Google,
we refer to that specification
as the Discovery document,
and that Discovery document,
or that metadata
about each one of the APIs
can then be used
in our client libraries
to build
the API calling surfaces.
And I know it's a really
simple diagram here,
but that's how simple
it really is.
It's a 2-step process,
and with that,
let me actually introduce you
to the APIs Discovery Service,
and it's the service
that exposes that metadata
about Google APIs
in machine-readable format
for client libraries
and other tools to consume,
and, uh, here's the link
to documentation.
You can also read through it
while we go ahead
with this session, and, uh...
So before Monsur comes up
and talks about the format,
let me quickly talk
about a few benefits
and the motivation for us to
release this service publicly.
So for first of all,
it's scalability.
At Google, we have over
a hundred different APIs,
and we also have a number
of programming languages
that we wish to support,
and even if we only were to pick
five different languages,
we would need to write 500
different client libraries
for those APIs.
This is obviously
not a scalable solution,
and this is not a Google-y way
of doing things,
so we obviously have
some sort of secret thing
behind--behind the scenes
that we use,
and this is
the Discovery Service.
The Discovery Service
really allows us
to reduce the amount
of work dramatically.
And here, if we build
a client library
that is built on top
of the Discovery Service,
it works for every single API
built on top of that service,
so we would--if all
of the hundred APIs
were on top
of the new infrastructure,
we would only need to build
five client libraries.
This is definitely
a huge improvement.
And another benefit that goes
along the side of scalability
is automation.
The Discovery Service--Oops--
The Discovery Service
also allows us to generate
a lot of other things
rather than client libraries.
Some of the documentation
that you see for newer APIs
on code.google.com
is also auto-generated
based on the Discovery Service,
and some of the documentation
for the client libraries,
such as Javadoc for Java
or pydoc for Python,
is also generated
based on the Discovery Service,
so this is a huge time-saver,
as you can--as you can imagine.
So the final benefit
and the real motivation
for us to release this service
publicly is transparency.
All of the new Google API client
libraries are open source.
However, up until today,
they were using
this undocumented endpoint,
which was the Discovery Service.
and by us, uh, open-sourcing
the libraries
and now announcing it
as the Discovery Service,
we really want to maintain
that story of transparency.
So with that,
let me quickly give you a demo
of a kind of tool you can build
on top of the APIs
Discovery Service,
and a few months ago,
we launched the APIs Explorer,
and this is an interactive
Web-based tool
for playing around and exploring
Google APIs in a browser,
and you can also
follow this link
and check it out
if you haven't yet.
What most of you
probably don't know
is that this tool is built
exclusively on top of
the APIs Discovery Service.
This means that all
of the information there
is not hard-coded,
is--comes from this service,
and is shown to you dynamically.
So another cool announcement--
that with the launch
of the Discovery Service,
we're also open-sourcing
the Explorer,
that you can actually go
and check it out how it's built
and see if you can build
similar tools yourself.
So let's quickly jump
into a demo of the Explorer,
and, uh, some of you
have probably seen this.
It has a listing of APIs.
It has a listing
of versions per API.
It has a listing of methods
in each version,
and finally, it has a number
of parameters for each method,
and all of this information
comes from
the Discovery Service.
All of that information,
along with all the description
of all the methods,
all the parameters,
and all of the APIs.
And just to give you an idea
of that scalability benefit,
some of the APIs that we
launched here at Google I/O
are already here.
We can see some
of the Page Speed Online API
that we launched at the sandbox,
Task Queue APIs that we launched
a little bit earlier,
and also
the Discovery API itself.
Since the Discovery Service
is built
on top of the new
API infrastructure,
it can actually describe itself,
and that's just to also give you
how cool this service actually
is and how geeky, as well.
I mean, it is, in fact, an API
of APIs that describes itself.
So with that, let's jump back
into the slides,
and a few other examples of how
this service is used at Google.
The new family of Google APIs
client libraries,
as I mentioned before,
in various languages,
is based on top of this service,
and you can look at the listing
of those libraries,
and you can jump in
and look at the code
and how the Discovery Service
is actually used.
And another cool thing
we launched about a month ago
is the Google API support
and the Google Plugin
for Eclipse,
and this gives you
an ability to import
Google API support
into your Eclipse project,
and this is also
a really cool thing
that we are very excited about.
So with that, let me
give it to Monsur,
who's gonna jump in
and give you an idea
of what kind of cool stuff
is available to you.
Hossain: All right,
thank you, Anton.
Uh, good morning, everybody.
So let's take a look at what
Discovery actually looks like.
So first of all, when we talk
about the Discovery Service,
we're actually talking
about two features.
We're talking about a directory
of the supported APIs,
and then we're talking
about a Discovery document
that describes a particular API.
All the responses
in the Discovery Service
are JSON-based,
and they're all served
from the URL that you see here.
Okay, so as Anton
just demo'ed earlier,
we just saw what
the APIs Explorer looks like.
Over here,
on the right-hand side,
you can see a list of services
to choose from.
That list of services
is generated
by the directory response.
So in order to access
the Dis--the directory response,
we visit the URL right there.
If you're following along
in your browser,
you can try that right now,
and you get the JSON response
you see here.
The JSON response
consists of an items array,
and then each element
in the array
describes a particular version
of a particular API.
So we currently have support
for the APIs you see here,
and, you know, this list is
probably out of date already.
They're probably--we're adding
more, um, as we go,
and as we add more APIs
onto the new infrastructure,
they'll show up
in the directory here.
As Anton mentioned, you can also
see discovery v1 is part of--
is one of those items
in that array.
Okay, so what information
do we have
about a particular API?
So we have identifying
information about the API,
stuff like its name,
its version, its description.
Then we have
documentation details,
uh, including a link
to the actual documentation,
as well as any icons
that go along with the API.
And then we have a link
to the Discovery document.
Now this is where
all the magic happens.
This is where you're gonna find
all the cool information
that you need to build a client
library, uh, for the API,
and we're gonna dive into
this Discovery document.
Before we do,
let's take a step back
and then take a look
at what an API looks like,
and in order to do that,
we're gonna use
the URL Shortener API.
For those of you
who aren't familiar
with the URL shortener feature,
or, uh, product,
it basically takes
a really long URL
and just squeezes it down
into a few characters.
You can see the example
that we have up here.
You've got this giant URL in red
that gets smushed down into
this shorter URL in green.
If you'd like to learn more
about the URL Shortener API,
you can visit the link you see
up there on the slide.
Okay, so what does the URL
Shortener API look like?
So to start out with,
you have resources.
This particular API has
one resource, the URL object,
and the resources
are basically the objects
that the API acts upon.
And then you have methods.
Methods are the actions
you can perform on an API.
For the URL Shortener API,
we've got three methods.
We've got a "get,"
"insert," and "list."
Also notice the last one,
the list method--
it requires authentication,
because it's returning details
about a particular user,
and we're gonna get into how
Discovery covers authentication
a little bit later in the talk.
Okay, so now we know
what the API looks like
that we're trying to model.
What does that look like
in Discovery?
So first, we need to request
the Discovery document
for a particular API.
We do that by visiting
the URL you see here.
You can notice
the name "URL Shortener"
and also the version v1
right there in the URL.
And we make this request
and we get back the JSON
response that you see here.
Again, let's take a look
at what types of information
we have in this response.
So we have the general
API details, which covers
a lot of the same details you
saw in the directory response.
We have
authentication information.
We have schema information,
which describes what the request
and response bodies look like.
We have a section for all
the resources in the API.
Here in this--
in the URL Shortener example,
we have the URL resource.
We have a--see the URL
right there.
And then, last thing,
we have a section
for all the methods that
go along with that resource.
So we're gonna dive into
thisMethods section
and see exactly
what information it has,
but before we do, let's take
a look at a generic HTTP request
to the URL Shortener API.
So here, I have the anatomy
of an HTTP request.
This is for the "get" method
on the URL Shortener API.
So basically,
you start out with--
we have the HTTP method,
which is "get,"
followed by the path
for the method itself,
and then any parameters
that go along--
uh, that are tagged onto
that path itself.
Here, we have
the short URL parameter,
so we bundle that all up
in an HTTP request.
We make the request,
and then we get
a JSON response body.
Okay, so what does this look
like in the Discovery document?
So to start out with,
like I mentioned earlier,
we've got a Methods section
that contains all the methods
on the URL resource.
I only had room to list
the "get" method here,
but you would also see
the "list" method
and the "insert" method.
And then inside
the "get" method,
you've got all the properties
to make that particular request,
so to start out with,
we have the HTTP method.
Uh, for the "get" method,
it's "get,"
but for inserts,
updates, and deletes,
it could also be "put,"
"post," or "delete."
Next, we have
the "path" property,
which basically tells you what
path to make the request to.
The "path" property is based on
URI Template v04 format.
And also notice
how it's not the full URL.
So let's take a segue into,
uh, also looking into
how to calculate the full URL
to make a request.
So here at the top here,
you see the full URL
for making a "get" request
to the URL Shortener API.
So how do we get this?
So we start by taking
the absolute URI
of the Discovery
document itself.
In this particular case,
it's https://www.googleapis.com.
To that, we add
the base "path" property.
Now the base "path" property
is gonna be found
at the top level
of the Discovery document,
and it's gonna be the base path
to which all the other paths
and the methods
are--are made relative to.
In this particular case,
it's a relative URI,
but it may, in the future,
also be an absolute URI.
And then, lastly,
we append to that
the "path" property
from the method itself.
Take these three pieces,
we smush 'em together,
and we've got the URL to which
to make the request.
Also, another note
about this "path" property--
Like I mentioned before,
it's based on
the URI Template v04 format,
which means that it
may contain variables
inside the path itself.
If you see one
of these curly braces,
it means it's a variable,
and it means you can also
learn more about
that particular variable
from the Parameters section
on the method.
I'll get into the Parameters
section in just a little bit.
Okay, so rounding out
the Methods section
on the Discovery document,
Uh, like I just mentioned,
we have a Parameters section,
and then we have any details
on what the request
and the responses look like.
Okay, so let's dive into
the parameters
for each particular method.
If a method has any parameters
in either the path or the query,
you're gonna find it
in this Parameters section.
So if you remember
from the HTTP example
I showed a few slides ago,
uh, for the "get" method,
we had a short URL parameter.
You can see over there,
on the right, how that maps onto
the Parameters section
of the Discovery document,
and you can see location query
to indicate that it's
a query parameter.
Some other information that's
included about the parameters.
You can get details about
what type the parameter is.
You see some valid values
up there.
You've got string, integer,
number, Boolean, or any.
And then you also have
any additional details
about that parameter.
You've got a description.
Um, if it's an enum,
you can have
all the enum values,
as well as descriptions
about those enums.
Then you can also
have information
about whether the parameter
is required or not.
These properties you see here
come from the JSON schema,
draft 03 spec.
Um, with parameters,
we've also made a few additions
to make parameters
a little bit clearer.
If you want to learn more
about JSON schema,
you can visit the link
that you see there.
Okay, so now we have details
on the methods and parameters.
We know how to make the request.
Now let's take a look
at the request
and the response body,
and the way we do that
is with schemas.
So basically, schemas show,
what do the requests
and the responses
of a method look like?
So at the top level
of the Discovery document,
outside of the methods,
outside of the resources,
you're gonna have
a schemas object,
and that's gonna contain
all the schemas
for the rest of
the Discovery document.
The schemas are identified
by a unique I.D.
In the URL Shortener example,
we have the URL schema.
The I.D. here is URL.
That I.D. is unique throughout
the Discovery document,
and it's used to refer back
to this particular schema.
So if you'll remember earlier,
from our Methods section,
we had a "response" property
to say that we had
a response body,
and it had a schema I.D. of URL.
We can take a look
at that schema I.D.,
jump back up
to the Schemas section,
and say, "Oh, it matched
to this URL here.
Here's where I can find
the schema for it."
Also note, really quick,
this $ref syntax.
If you see that, that's borrowed
from the JSON referencing syntax
of, uh, the JSON
schema specification.
If you see $ref,
just know that the value
is a schema I.D.
that points to a schema
in the Schemas section.
And then, finally, you have
the actual schema itself.
Like I mentioned earlier,
we're using JSON Schema
draft 03, as well,
and to get an idea
about how this schema maps
to an actual response,
let's go back and look over
there on the left-hand side.
You'll see the response
from the "get" method.
It had such properties as I.D.,
kind, and long URL.
And then you can look
over on the right
to the JSON schema itself,
and you can see
how those properties are modeled
in the JSON schema.
You can see how they provide
additional information,
such as type information
or description information.
Okay, so that kind of tells you
how to make a request,
but what if--what if a method
needs authentication?
So there's a lot
of methods on APIs
that do require authentication.
In the URL Shortener API,
we saw that the list method
needed authentication.
When you're
doing authentication,
we're gonna be talking about
the OAuth 2 specification.
If you want to learn more
about OAuth 2,
you can visit the link
we have there,
or there's a talk later on today
that covers OAuth 2.
OAuth 2 is supported
by most APIs
on the new
Google APIs infrastructure.
Now when you're doing OAuth 2,
we have these strings
called scopes
that indicate what kind
of permissions you have,
uh, when making requests
against the API.
They can say whether or not
you can make
a read and write request
or whether you can make
a read-only request.
So Discovery works
by documenting the scopes
for a particular API.
So let's take a look
at what this Auth section
actually looks like.
So again, at the top level
of the Discovery document,
you're gonna have
an Auth section.
That's gonna contain all
the auth-related information
about that particular API.
Now we've got an OAuth 2
and a Scopes section,
because right now,
we're focusing on documenting
only the OAuth 2 scopes.
We have the value
of the scope itself,
and then lastly,
we have any additional
information about that scope,
such as, uh, the description.
So now how do we
map those scopes
back onto our actual methods?
Well, here, we have an example
of the "list" method
from the URL Shortener API.
You remember, earlier,
the "list" method
requires authentication,
and because it does,
you'll see that it has
a scopes array,
and each value
in that scopes array
points back to a scope
in the Auth section.
So that way, you know that
for this particular method,
it supports this scope here,
and you've got
some more information
about how you could actually
do authentication
uh, for a--
for particular methods.
Okay, so that kind of gives you
an overview
of what the Discovery document
looks like.
A couple other things
about the Discovery document
to keep in mind.
Uh, one is that most objects,
most properties,
as much as you can,
in the Discovery document,
is gonna--are gonna have
a "description" property.
This includes methods,
parameters, and schemas,
and the "description" property
is basically
a human-readable description
about that particular property,
so this is really useful in,
you know, documentation,
or client library documentation.
You may have also seen it
in the APIs Explorer.
It just basically gives you
an indication
of what the property
actually does,
so keep an eye out for that,
and as you new--
add new properties,
they'll probably have
"description" properties
along with them, as well.
Okay, so lastly, some other tips
when using
the Discovery Service.
One is that this service
is SSL only.
If you saw, in all the examples,
we were using HTTPS, not HTTP.
You don't need an API key
to access the Discovery Service.
If you go into some of the other
talks here at Google I/O
or you're already familiar
with the APIs,
you may have noticed
a "key" property
up there in the query parameter.
You don't need that to use
the Discovery Service,
and we did that basically
to eliminate confusion
between, you know,
the key for Discovery
versus the key
for the API itself.
Um, the examples that I saw--
that you've seen here--
basically have methods
inside of resources,
but note that the API itself
may have methods
that aren't connected
to any particular resource.
We call these methods
API-level methods,
and if an API has them,
they'll be right there
at the top level
of the Discovery document.
So in the same vein,
resources themselves could also
contain nested resources,
so that's all something
to keep out for
when you're walking through
the Discovery document.
Schema references,
as I mentioned earlier--
if you see this $ref syntax,
just know the value
is a schema I.D.,
which then points to a schema
up in the Schema section.
Uh, URI Templates--
the "path" property
is based on URI Templates,
so if you see curly brackets,
just know the value inside
that curly brackets
is pointing to a parameters
in the Parameters section,
where you can learn more about
what that variable means.
And then, lastly, if you're
doing authentication,
be sure to read up
on how OAuth 2 works.
Okay, so that gives you an idea
of what the Discovery document
actually looks like.
Now Joe's gonna come up
and tell you how to use
the Discovery document
to actually build
a client library.
Gregorio: Thanks, Monsur.
So we've got
this great document.
How are we actually going
to use it and consume it?
Three simple steps, actually.
The first thing you do is,
obviously, fetch
the Discovery document
for the API you're interested
in talking to.
Build a resource and a request
based on that.
When you actually do that,
we'll get to in a little bit.
And then finally,
make that RESTful call
and fetch the response.
So what I'm gonna show you is
a simple Python client example.
Okay, this is fully functional
in that it works on,
you know, on these APIs.
It's only 35 lines of Python.
There's definitely things
it does not do,
so it is not complete, but it's
a very good starting point.
So there it is--
35 lines of code.
Entire library--not only
entire library,
but the last two lines
actually show
using the library,
so at the bottom, you'll see
we've built a service object
based on the Discovery.
Discovery, at this point,
is a deserialized
Discovery document
for, in this case,
the URL shortener,
and that collection object
is what we're going to start
attaching our methods to
to build up that API service.
And then, in the very next line,
we actually call into
that service.
We call service, we call .url,
because, remember,
that's the collection,
that's the resource
in the URL Shortener API.
We insert, there,
and then we pass in a body,
which is that JSON body
that we're going to post,
so that's the URL
that we want to be shortened.
We then--that gets executed,
and we return the result.
So let's look at what we've got
goin' on here.
So just to show there's nothing
up my sleeve here,
these are the only five imports
that are there.
Now the JSON urlparse
and urllib
are part of the Python
standard library.
The httplib2 library
just makes it very easy
to make HTTP requests,
and the uritemplate library
is a third-party library
for expanding URI Templates.
So let's get those
out of the way
so we've got a little more space
to see what's going on.
So the very first thing we do
is we're gonna start Step 1--
fetch the Discovery document.
So you see here,
that URI is for
the Discovery document
for the URL Shortener
service v1.
I request it,
and then in this case,
I, uh, convert that
into a Python data structure
from the JSON.
Next step is
I start going through
that process
that Monsur talked about
of how do you construct the URL
that you're gonna make
that request to?
So this is the first part of it.
I'm going to take that base URI,
where the Discovery
document was.
I join that up
with that relative URI
that's available in base path.
Join that up. Now I've got
that base URI
for the service itself.
Here's just a simple
collection object.
This is where I'm gonna start
attaching methods to.
Gregorio: Now here's
our build call, right?
We want this to be passed in
a Discovery document,
and we're gonna start attaching
methods and attributes
to that collection object
to start--build up
our API service,
so the very first thing we do
is we loop over all
of the resource sections
that are available
at that level
in the Discovery document,
so that's
that "for name, resource
in discovery, get 'resources'."
Um, there might not be any,
so be careful of that.
Iterate all of--all over--
all of those,
and then, for each of those,
these are actually going
to be nested resources, right?
That was one of the things
Monsur said to be careful of.
You could have
nested resources in here.
So you'll notice, what we do is
we attach that result
of recursing into ourselves
onto that collection,
so that gets us
our nested resources.
The next loop is we're gonna
loop over all the methods,
so we loop over all the methods.
We call "create new method,"
give it the name,
and that constructs a new method
that we then attach
to that collection object.
So here's the real meat,
the "create new method."
This is a method factory, right?
We come in here,
and what do we do?
We attach this method to it.
The first thing it does is
it looks at all the parameters
that are passed in.
We pop off the body,
'cause that's where bodies
are going to be.
That's actually gonna be sent
as the HTTP body
that gets sent over
in a request, if there's any.
Now we start finishing up
that process
that Monsur talked about
of constructing that URI.
So we take that base URI
and we now add on the path part
for the method
that we're dealing with.
After that--
and we notice,
we used the URI Template,
so we're gonna take
that path part
and expand it as a URI Template
and attach that,
so now we've got that full URI
with the domain name
and then the path.
Now we have to figure out
what the query parameters are,
so we look at
the Parameters section
of the Discovery document.
We look in there,
and we actually take out
anything that should have been
already used in the path.
All right, knock those out,
so that's where the delete key
with all these
pnames comes from.
We're taking all
of those things out.
What's left over should be
all the stuff that's supposed
to go in the query parameters.
So if there's anything left,
I URL encode it,
I attach that to the URL,
and now I'm ready
to make my request,
so "h" is my httplib2 object
for making requests.
Call request.
I've calculated the URL.
I make the call.
The method is also
in the Discovery document,
under the "HTTP method"
property.
There's my body.
That gets sent over straight,
and then the headers--in this
case, we're dealing with JSON,
so we have to add that.
And that's it.
So then here, now you can see
what happens, right?
We call build, with that
Discovery document,
we attach it
to that empty collection,
and then I've got a surface
there that I'm able to use
to make the requests.
So let's try this live.
So here's the code, again,
that we were just talking about,
available here,
and if we go and run that--
From the command line,
we see what gets returned
is that, uh,
the response
from shortening that URI.
Gregorio: Okay, so when I built
this up, I'm doing Python.
Python is a dynamic language,
so I'm actually making
that request as I run,
and I'm building up
my surface at runtime.
If you're using
a strongly typed language,
you may not want to do that,
so you may actually want to--
uh, and we do this
in Java ourselves,
request ahead of time.
Use that Discovery document
to actually create a Java
library, which is then compiled,
and then you can, you know,
use that in your process,
in, uh, in your program.
So, like I said,
dynamically languages,
you can--you can do that,
and there's various
levels, right?
You have to decide
what language you're in
and what pros and cons are
for doing each of those.
So that was the simple
Python client.
We did that working demo.
That is a really, really,
really stripped-down version
of the Google APIs Python client
that we have out there.
It is a fully
functional library--
covers all those areas that
that 35 lines of Python code
did not do.
It does parameter checking.
It checks the parameter names.
Um, it deals
with authentication.
What you saw
when I did that request
is I actually had to type in
the straight JSON
that was going over the wire.
The Python client library
takes care of that for you,
where you just pass it
a Python data structure
and it'll serialize it
into Python for you,
so lots of--lots of help
that way.
This is what that same
exact code would look like
if you were using
the API Python client library,
so we just import
the build function
from apiclient discovery.
We say build urlshortener, v1.
That goes out and does
just what I did
in that 35-line client--
35 lines of code, but a lot
more comprehensively,
I built up a surface there,
and then I call
service url insert,
and you'll notice there
that the body is actually
a Python data structure.
That'll get serialized.
I call execute,
and that gives me the exact
same response as we just saw.
There's the URI
for downloading it
if you want to look at that
a little more deeply.
We have libraries
built on Discovery
in a variety of languages,
so we've got
Java and Python libraries
that are available in beta,
and PHP, Ruby, and .NET
that are available in alpha.
Now beta for us means
that we're very happy with
how that project is going.
Things have settled down.
We're not looking at
breaking changes coming in,
as far as we know.
We're in bugfixing.
We'd like you to,
you know, to dig in
and start using these libraries.
Um, alpha means
under construction.
We're--we're dealing--
you know, we may make
breaking changes to the library.
They're being actively,
you know, worked on,
um, so please use,
but use at your own risk.
Know what you're getting into,
that, you know,
things may change on you.
So let me hand it back
to, uh, Anton to wrap it up.
Lopyrev: Thanks, Joe.
Um, this is really cool.
I hope you guys really
understand what just happened.
I mean, that's
a really small library,
but it's so functional that you
can actually use that library
to access
the Discovery Service itself,
and then build another library
to discover itself,
so it's an infinite
recursion, really,
which is really cool.
So with that, let's quickly
do a review of what we did here,
and we covered the Google APIs
Discovery Service,
which is the service
that provides you
machine-readable specification
of other APIs,
and, uh, this is the link
documentation again.
Feel free to check it out,
and it's used today
by the Google APIs Explorer.
It's used today by the Google
API client libraries
and Google Plugin for Eclipse.
So what's next is you should
explore the format.
Take a look at the code
of the APIs Explorer.
of client libraries,
and what we really want to know
is what kind of stuff
you can build with this,
whether you're gonna build other
client libraries
in various languages
that we don't currently have,
whether you can build
IDE plugins, such as
for IntelliJ, Visual Studio,
or your favorite I.D.,
or whether you want to build
your own explorers,
whether you want to build an API
explorer on your Android phone,
you want to build
an API explorer on your iPhone,
whatever works for you,
so this is what
we're really excited about.
We wanted you to help out
our story for our developers.
So with that,
thank you very much,
and if you still want
to tweet about some stuff,
feel free to go ahead,
and we do want your feedback,
so please submit it
on this link,
and we're now open
for questions. Thanks, everyone.
[applause]
man: Hi, I've got one.
Um, you mentioned,
uh, nested resources.
Is that related to--
I mean, obviously,
the URL shortener was a very
simple example, deliberately.
The app only had
an implicit, uh, collection.
Is that where
nested resources come in,
when you have multiple
collections and so on,
or do they relate at all?
Gregorio: Yeah,
so the collections
are the resources.
There's kind of a naming
mismatch there, but yeah,
when we say the resources
in the Discovery document--
if you were at the,
uh, the BootCamp lab,
where we talked about...
man: Yeah.
Gregorio: That's gonna be
your collection,
and then there's gonna be those
methods on that collection.
man: Okay, thanks.
man: So if I want to build
my own API and use your tools,
is that--are the tools
also open source,
the compiler that
takes the document
and converts it into--
into Java or Python?
Lopyrev: Um, so I-I believe
the question
was whether or not the tools
for some of the libraries
that we have are available,
such as, like, for Java?
Is that what you--
man: You mentioned
you take the document
and convert it into,
like, a proxy, right, or that
you can use from your clients?
Lopyrev: Mm... I'm not sure
if I exactly understand.
So, I mean, you can use
any typical HTTP library
to pull down the document.
man: Yeah, but then
I take the document
and I want to use it
to call the API.
I want to have code that I can
easily call, so I don't have
to put together the "get"
request and all this stuff"--
Lopyrev: So the idea is you can,
like, to then call the APIs
as you just construct the URL,
and you use a typical HTTP
library to make the call,
such as whether
it's httplib in Python
or, you know, Apache,
or HTTP library in Java,
or something like that.
So those tools are already
available to you as standard,
like, standard tools that are in
a lot of environments.
Gregorio: So, but--for--
I think you're asking
if, you know, if we've
open-sourced the tool we used
to convert that Discovery
document into Java.
man: Right.
Lopyrev: Oh, is that what
the question--my bad.
Gregorio: So is that--yeah.
man: It's complicated.
Lopyrev: Um, for Java, I'm not
sure, actually. Did we?
Is that part of the library?
Gregorio: We did not
open-source that yet.
Python is there,
so the Python--
Lopyrev: Yeah, for Java,
it's not yet,
but we'll definitely look into
putting that out there
for an example,
as well, how to use it.
man: And do you have a tool
to create the implementation
of the document--
out of the document--
you know, so I have a service...
Lopyrev: Yeah.
man: That I want to--
that I describe as the document?
I know I want to--
Lopyrev: Not currently.
It's--the format is there,
and part of this launch,
we're also opening up
the pattern, that you are free
to use the format
for your own services,
so we don't have any tool
specifically for you to--
like, implement it
as part of your service,
but you should--
free to go ahead with that.
Hossain: It's a good idea.
Lopyrev: And one
of the cool things here
is that once you actually do
take advantage of that service
and for your own services,
you can then use some of
the Google client libraries
to access your service.
man: Right, right. Thanks.
man: Is Google's plan to make
all of their APIs discoverable
via this, uh, mechanism?
What kind of a timeline
for getting any...
Lopyrev: It's a--it will be
a long and painful process,
but we're working on it.
man: Okay.
Um, and that's gonna include
the paid APIs,
where there's usage restrictions
on the number of calls
and things like that?
Lopyrev: Yeah, it's
our long-term goal
to try to convert everybody
to a common infrastructure.
man: Hi. So I just want
to make sure
that I have this
understood conceptually.
The idea is not that you're
gonna save people time
understanding the documentation
and all the methods
and how to call them.
The idea is that you're
providing an easy way
for people to create
an object in their code
that sort of models the APIs.
Is that correct?
Hossain: Right.
Lopyrev: Um, there are
a lot of different ways
we can see people using it.
That's definitely one of them,
and that's one of the things
we're also trying to accomplish
with this launch.
We want to really see what kind
of stuff people can use it for.
Yes, one of the great ways to
use it for is you can actually--
Let's see, you're building--
all you want to do
is access Buzz API,
and Buzz API
as an activities object,
and you want to construct
that object in your code
in order to make a call
to the Buzz API.
You can definitely do that.
Hossain: Also, all these APIs
on this new Google
infrastructure,
they're all speaking
the same protocol,
so the idea is you'd be able
to write a client library
that speaks that protocol.
You know, you'd consult
the documentation.
You speak that protocol. You do
OAuth 2, all that stuff.
Then you can grab the Discovery
document for a particular API,
and it'll layer on functionality
for that particular API
on top of that protocol.
So the idea is, once you've
built that base client,
you would basically
have a client library
for any API built on
this new infrastructure.
man: Okay, or--and one
other thought is,
I suppose that any time
you guys update your APIs,
um, with the Discovery Service,
those are automatically updated
within your code.
Lopyrev: So the idea is that,
yes, some of--first of all,
we do versioning in our APIs,
so as you saw,
each one of the Discovery
documents is versioned,
so and then at Google,
we try and--
we do not make any breaking
changes to existing versions,
or we at least try to attempt
as much as we can.
And the idea is that
if something happened,
that, let's say we made
a change in an API, it will be
automatically reflected
in the Discovery document,
but also, if we made
a new version of APIs,
you can then pull out
the new Discovery document
for that specific version.
man: I can't help to, uh,
see a lot of similarities
between this
and WSDL from years back,
and, I mean, I really do
appreciate the usages of WSDL,
but it was flawed in a couple
different areas.
Do you know if there--
I'm sorry, not flawed,
but, uh, REST is taking
a whole different approach.
It's almost like finding
the best of both worlds
here with
the Discovery document.
But do you see
any outside people
using the Discovery document,
outside of Google?
Lopyrev: Do you want me--
I can take that one, I guess.
Um, we're not trying to push
for a standard right now.
It's definitely something
we thought about,
and, uh, one of the things
we want to do right now--
we're launching this in
our Labs program, so that means
we're not committing fully
to the format just yet.
We--as I mentioned just now
is that--
we really want to see
what people use,
and whether some information
might be missing still.
We want to see what other
feature requests
we're gonna get, so maybe
somewhere down the road,
we might push it for a protocol,
or who knows?
But at this point,
we definitely would like
to see some people
to take advantage of it.
Hossain: We've taken a very, uh,
client-centric approach
towards developing this service.
Like, we worked really closely
with the APIs Explorer,
the client libraries,
to make sure that Discovery
meets their needs, and I think
part of the reason we want
to put this out to everybody
is, like, we want to make sure
that it meets the needs
of all our developers,
not just the ones internally,
and I feel like we could
go through a process
where we were just building it,
making it useful for developers.
and then once we--
then we could maybe start
that other conversation,
but we're not right there yet.
Lopyrev: Yeah.
man: It just seems like
it would be very useful.
Hossain: I mean, we use--yeah,
we definitely encourage you,
if you feel like it'd be useful
for your own APIs,
feel free to create
a Discovery document
and--and play around
with our client libraries.
man: So you guys don't have
any licensing agreements
or anything restricting
modeling that?
Gregorio: You can look at the--
you can look at
the docs up there.
There's a patent license.
Lopyrev: But it's pretty much
free-for-all.
Please feel free to use.
Gregorio: Yeah.
Obviously, we can't
give you lawyerly advice,
but you can--it's two sentences,
and it should be pretty clear
on what--what you're
getting into there.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Um, I have a question.
I mean, actually, to come back,
I've been thinking
about this similar kind
of Discovery document
when I was working
on some Android application
where I'm trying to cache
a lot of the data,
so to discover the service
and then create, let's say,
my SQL Live database.
So have you thought about,
like, instead of marshaling,
let's say, to some kind
of Java object or Python object,
marshal it to some SQL
kind of relationship?
Um, from the JSON, for instance?
Has that been anything
you've been thinking about?
Lopyrev: Um, that's
an interesting--
very interesting idea.
We haven't really
thought of that,
but yeah, it's a great use case,
and I guess just, uh, confirms
our idea of releasing it
and see what kind of cool stuff
you can come up with.
[chuckles) Yeah, that's great.
I mean, that sounds like--
very usable. Good idea.
man: One more question.
If I were to run past
these slides really quickly,
I would have noticed resources
and URIs and kinds and stuff,
and I would have thought,
this is a presentation on RDF.
I was just wondering
whether you'd thought about
that sort of, uh, angle
on managing the resources
and the relationships
between the stuff,
or is that just technology
for technology's sake?
I'm justdreaming this.
Are there any other implications
or any--any inspirations
from that area?
Gregorio: Um, as far as--sorry.
As inspiration from RDF,
or doing RDF-type things
with the document
now that it's out there?
man: The latter.
Gregorio: The last one. Um,
we haven't, but, I mean, again,
that's why we're here
and putting this out.
If somebody wants to do that,
you know, that would--
that'd be interesting to see.
man: Okay, thanks.
Lopyrev: Cool.
All right, thanks, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Gregorio: Thanks.
Hossain: Take care.
[applause]